حياكم الله في بودكاست السوق من ثمانيه
حلقتنا اليوم حلقه دسمه خصوصا للي يحبون
الارقام لانه راح نتكلم عن جولتين مهمتين
واستراتيجيتين في المنطقه وكلهم من طراز
جيم او ما تعرف بالسيريز سي جوله 156
مليون دولار وجوله نعناع 133 مليون دولار
راح يكون اغلب الحلقه نقاش مفتوح حول
الشركتين وخصوصا فلورد بعد ما انتشر ملف
يذكر في اهم يعني ارقام ومؤشرات هالشركه
واللي اعلنت انها تستعد للطرح العام خلال
السنتين او الثلاثه القادمه بعد ذلك راح
نتكلم بشكل موجز عن اهم الاخبار اللي صدرت
من المنظومه المحليه السعوديه من خلال
مؤتمر ليب من اخبار صناديق من اخبار
صناديق دينجيري ومن اخبار ايضا بنيه تحتيه
ومشاريع تنمويه وايضا محفزات حكوميه اذا
اعجبك هذا المحتوى لا تنسى انك تشاركه مع
شخص مهتم بهذا النوع من المحتوى ودائما
ومثل كل مره اقول لكم استمتعوا
[موسيقى]
طبعا بدايه 20 23 بدايه ساخنه شفنا
الاسبوع الماضي في مصر
ولاده يونيكورن ام ان تي حالا جمع مبلغ
زاد عن ال 400 مليون دولار في جوله واحده
استثنائيه
الاسبوع هذا شفنا الاعلان عن العديد من
الجولات ايضا الاستثنائيه شفنا
نعناع ودي صراحه نبدا نتكلم عن فلاند
واللي اغلقت جوله من طراز جيم بقيمه 156
مليون دولار الجوله كانت بقياده كل من اس
تي في
الجزيره كافيتو هو دخول يعني خلينا نقول
فريد من نوعه لبنك تقليدي الى حد ما قطاع
الملكيه الخاصه او البرايفت اكويتي قرروا
انهم يسوون صندوق خاص بالفرصه هذه ويجمعون
210 مليون ريال او س مليون دولار في سابقه
قد تكون يعني مبشره يعني
بالخير القادم لانه دائما نتكلم عن يعني
وجود هذه الفجوه في المراحل المتاخره
مراحل الجيم وما قبل يعني الطرح العام
جوله استثنائيه
خصوصا بعد العام الماضي الشركه جمعت
34.2 مليون دولار في جوله من طراز بي
وكانت بقياده اس تي في وامباكت
شركه جمعت مجموع 34 مليون
27 ونصف مليون منها كان في الجوله اللي
ذكرتها
المثير لما تشوف التصريح الشركه والمؤسس
يقول لك تضاعف تقييم الشركه
3.8 مرات قريب من 4 مرات خلال 18 شهر مما
يعني اداء خرافي لهم وكان اعلان من
الاعلانات الجميله في في ليب كذلك شد
انتباهي كيف حطوا وما قالوا عدد الطلبات
لكن قالوا وصلنا خمسين مليون ورده في عام
قعدت احاول احسبها
136 الف ورده وشوي باليوم او اذا
ابتسامه في اليوم
اذا معدل الطلب عشر وردات يعني
طلبيه في اليوم ما شاء الله عليهم لكن
واضح ان في حماس على وش يبغون يسوون في في
المبلغ ابو عبد العزيز كنا نتكلم عن
الموضوع المبلغ
تصريح ما كان بس يعني نجاح جمع الجوله لكن
كان في وضوح في وين يبون يصرفون المبلغ
صحيح صحيح انا يعني حظيت عبد العزيز
اللغاني مؤسس مخضرم وكان متواجد بالرياض
الاسبوع الماضي بعد ما شكرته على انقاذ
انقاذي كانت متزوج من خلال العروض
الموجوده عنده من مره سالته يعني وش تعليق
على الوضع اللي قاعد يصير يعني في المنظمه
بشكل عام وشدد العزيز على انه الان يعني
اثبتت انه وصلنا الى مرحله صار عند
المؤسسين الجدد وشركات الناشئه اللي توها
طالعه خيار ما كان متوفر بشكل واضح سابقا
وهذا خيار هو خيار الاستحواذ الاندماج من
قبل اللاعبين كبار مراحل متاخره زي فلور
وحتى يعني ذكر انه بالنسبه الفتره الجايه
عمليات الاستحواذ الاندماجات راح تكون
ركيزه اساسيه في استراتيجيه النمو بالنسبه
لهم على اكثر من مستوى طبعا يمكن تكلمنا
قبل اربعه او خمس حلقات عن استحواذ قامت
فيه فلاورد لشركه مبخر الكويتيه وهو نوع
من التوسع الافقي طبعا بدات في مجال اهداء
الورود وكان هذا تركيزها الرئيسي وحتى
اسمها مستقبل كلمه فلاورز لكن مع الوقت
بدات تتوسع في المنتجات اللي معروضه على
المنصه وكانها تتحول يعني الى حد ما الى
منصه الاهداء الاولى
يعني دخلوا في مجال التشوكليت دخلوا في
مجال البخور
الاكسسوارات وغيرها من الامور ويبدو انه
فعلا يعني استراتيجيتهم هي الاستحواذ اولا
خصوصا على
الشركاء اللي يكملونهم ويكملون يعني سلسله
الاهداء هذه كامله ومبخر كان مثال جيد
ويتضح من خلال المبلغ اللي جمعوه يعني
المبلغ اعتقد جزء جيد منه راح يتوجه في
هذا الاتجاه خصوصا بما انه صار عندنا يعني
نظره عامه عن وضع الشركه المالي
وذلك من خلال يعني ملف انتشر في تزامنا مع
الجوله هذه
عن الجزيره كابيتال طبعا يعني للتوضيح
الجزيره كابيتال هم مؤسسين زي صندوق خاص
بهذه الفرصه
استهداف الصندوق انه يجمع 210 مليون ريال
او سته وخمسين في مليون دولار من الجوله
وهذه يمثل تقريبا ثلث الجوله فعاده هذه
الصناديق تحتاج انها تجمع الاموال هذه
يعني المال المستثمر ليس مال البنك مباشره
وان كان البنك يعني ممكن يضع جزء من اموال
الخاصه
في الفرصه مباشره ولكن يجمع بقيه الاموال
من مستثمرين افراد او مكاتب عائليه الى
اخره فانتشر هذا الملف وصراحه يعني
في بودكاست السوق احنا يمكن دائما نواجه
معضله
وهي ان ما نقدر نصرح بارقام الشركات او
حتى يعني بعض الاستراتيجيات الخاصه فيها
بسبب اطلاعنا عليها تحت
ظروف تعتبر او تتطلب السريه في حال والله
وصلت يعني العرض التقديمي لشركه
او يعني عرض او تحديث شهري لشركه من خلال
المؤسسين او من خلال صندوق او او فبالتالي
هذا الشيء صعب علينا عمليه يعني تحليل هذه
الشركات
بسبب ان المعلومات ما هي بمعلومات يعني
موجوده عندنا وطبعا في نفس الوقت عندنا
غياب في الصحافه الاستقصائيه في المجال
التقني الرياضي يعني ما عندنا والله جهات
تروح وهي تبحث بنفسها عن هذه المعلومات
وتحاول انها يعني تستنتجها او تستنبطها
وافضل مثال على ذلك عمليه
التسريحات اللي صارت في المنطقه يعني احنا
تكلمنا عن الكثير من الش الامريكيه التي
سوت تسريحات وبنفس الوقت يمكن ما تكلمنا
الا عن شركتين او ثلاثه محليه سوى
التسريحات لكن الحقيقه ان الكثير من
الشركات المحليه سواء التسريحات لكن ما
نقدر نتكلم عنها بسبب ان معرفتنا بهذه
التسريحات جت عن الطريق مصادر خاصه وليست
مصادر عامه فاليوم صراحه انا يعني ودي
ننتهز هالفرصه بسبب وجود يعني ملف
تم اصداره بشكل شبه عام وانتشر في العديد
من الجروبات ووسائل التواصل يتحدث عن شركه
يعطينا فرصه اننا نفهم الشركه بشكل افضل
من الداخل وحسب ما فهمت يعني لغه الملف
مكتوب عليه انه هذا تيزر تشويقا وما في اي
عبارات عن السريه وخصوصيه فان شاء الله ان
الارقام نتكلم عنها يعني مفيده للمنظومه
وهي بشكل عام يعني تنعكس ايجابا على اللي
قاعد يصير بس احنا نبغى يعني ندخل اليوم
نفصفصه نفككها شوي ونشوف يعني كيف ممكن
تطالع الفرصه
للشركه وخصوصا يعني انه نيتهم سابقا
واكدوها الان من خلال الملف اعلنهم راح
يتخرجون في في فتره قريبه الملفت ايضا
تسميه الصندوق يعني الجزيره كابتل برايفت
اكويتي واللي هي ملكيه خاصه وهذا يدلك
الان انه وصلنا للمرحله بشركاتنا انه
بدينا نشوف تداخل بين عالمين
الاستثمار رسمي للجريء للشركات الرياديه
وعالم استثمارات الملكيه الخاصه لاعاده
المخصصه الشركات الاكثر نضج فالجميل نبدا
نشوف هل الظاهره اللي ما كانت منتشره بشكل
واسع قبل انا هنا وليد ودي اضيف بس نقطه
قبل ما نخش في الملف والتعليقاتنا على
الملف واللي هي يعني احنا فعلين يوم بدينا
البودكاست هذا كنا نقول انه ودنا ننقل
الاحاديث اللي عاده تصير في الاستراحات او
تصير في المكاتب المغلقه واللي اذا
اجتمعنا مثلا حنا الثلاثه ولا انت وبعض من
الزملاء في نفس المجال راح تتكلمون فيها
ويكون فيها فعلا معلومات خلنا نقول على
الاقل يعني مثيره وممكن انها تنور الشخص
وتنور مداركه باي شكل من الاشكال فاليوم
فعلا هي فرصه
يعني لتحقيق ذلك من خلال يعني مناقشه
هالملف واللي مطروح سواء يعني من ارقام من
مؤشرات وغيرها وش في الملف يمكن ابدا
تضيفون المعلومات الاخرى لكن يعني واضح ان
الكلام او في كلام على التقييم
انه بحدود او
خلينا نقول بحدود 433 مليون دولار لكنه
ليس رقم التقييم مباشر لانه يشمل الاسهم
الرئيسه وكذلك شراء الاسهم الثانويه من
مستثمرين سابقين فالرقم التقييم الشركه
الفعلي في الغالب اعلى لكن مو واضح بكم
لانه يعتمد على عدد وسعر الاسهم الثانويه
اللي ناويين يشترونها كذلك ابو عبد العزيز
ذكرت التخرج من خلال ادراج العام النيه
ثلاث سنوات
وما ودي اتكلم عن العائد المتوقع يمكن
نتكلم عنها بعد شويه لما نيجي الامور
الماليه او الجوانب الماليه لكن كان في
سنه سيناريوات كثيره
لكن يبدو ان الضعف هو الرقم المستهدف صحيح
الضعف ايرار 25% خلال ثلاث سنوات يعطيك تو
اكس
والنيه تخارج من خلال البورصه السعوديه
فهذه ايضا يعني كانت ملفته كيف يبغون
يوصلون لهذا النمو
تكلمنا يمكن قبل شوي من كلام المؤسس وليد
على الاستحواذات والاندماجات واضح جدا انه
بيكون لها دور كبير واضح اثرها كذلك في
الجانب المالي خصوصا في الربحيه كذلك نوع
احد اهم المجالات كذلك التركيز في التسويق
على جانب اعاده الشراء هذا غالبا حيكون
جانب كبير
والنقطه الثالثه اعتقد كانت رفع رفع او
التحسين تجربه العميل بشكل كبير مختلف
قنوات الشركه طيب انا ودي صراحه يعني
نتناول بعض الارقام اللي موجوده اول شيء
نتكلم عن عدد العملاء يعني في عام 2022
كان عندهم قرابه ال800 الف عميل تقريبا
نمو حول يعني سبعين 80% عن العام السابق
480 الف عميل في عشرين
لكن زي ما ذكرت وليد الملف يعني بما انه
ملف عام وله ملف يعني يذكر كل شيء بعمق
غير ما يتضح لنا اذا هذولي العملاء هم
فعالين ولا هم المسجلين في المنصه
فيعني التقديراتنا تقدير الشخصي صراحه بعد
قراءه الملف انه هذا ليس رقم العملاء
الفعالين وانما يعني هذا رقم العملاء بشكل
عام وقد اكون يعني مخطئ لكن الملف على
الاقل لا يوضح يعني بتفصيل لكن نروح
للمبيعات مبيعات عام 20 21 كانت
95 مليون دولار بين مبيعات 2022
اقتربت من 150 مليون دولار ويعني حققوا
نمو تقريبا سنه عن سنه سته وخمسين في
الميه طبعا عشرين يعني لم تكن السنه
الاسهل
عند الكثير من القطاعات خصوصا في قطاع
يعني يعتبر
اللي هو فيتامين اكثر من انه يعني والله
دواء للعملاء لانه انت في النهايه قاعد
تهدي في مناسبات يعني حتى اكيد في مناسبات
رئيسيه مثل يعني ولاده وتخرج وغيرها لكن
في مناسبات ايضا تكون ثانويه فيعني قد
يكون نسبه النمو مرتبطه الى حد كبير
بالصعوبات الاقتصاديه اللي واجهتها الكثير
من الشركات لكن بنفس الوقت يعني ودي اطرح
سؤال مدري اذا تتفقون او لا ما تحسون ان
يعني نسبه النمو على
[موسيقى]
المبيعات اللي هي 95 مليون دولار للعامل
السابق انها نسبه يعني متواضعه ولا تشوفون
العكس تماما يعني قبل ما جابوا هالسؤال
لاني لاحظت انه التواجد الجغرافي للشركه
غير منطقه الخليج ويمكن مصر والاردن مؤخرا
ايضا بريطانيا لشكلت واحد بالمئه تقريبا
من المبيعات فحاولت افكر ليش لكن يبدو ان
واحده من الافكار وهذه اللي يحاول يعني
يبرزها الملف انه
تبغى تعتمد على تعزيز تاثير الشبكه عنده
من خلال شراء الهدايا عن او عبر الحدود او
عبر المدن فبالتالي في جاليات معينه مثلا
موجوده في السوق الرئيسي لها بالخليج اللي
ممكن تبغى تشتري الاقاربها واصحابها في
الدول الثانيه فقد يكون هذا واحده من
محاور نموها الشيء الاخر يركز عليه الملف
انه الفئه المستهدفه هي فئه ضيقه فعليا
الديموغرافيا من 20 الى 35 سنه اللي
بالنسبه التعريف اللي موجود يعني هذول او
المحل الاهل او مواطنين العالم الرقمي
بشكل رئيسي ولعل الاستحواذا راح تعملها
الشركه بالذات خارج عالم الورد قد توسع
السوق المستهدف او التام هنا بشكل كبير
يساعد في دفع عجله النمو بشكل اكبر الان
فانا 56% على شركه يعني لسه رايحه على اي
بي او يمكن ما يكون بالشكل العالي كفايه
لكن الملف ايضا يتوقع انهم يوصلون سنه 25
الى تقريبا 450 مليون دولار
من المبيعات وبالتالي اذا يعني طبقت معامل
تقييم او مكرره تقييم على اثنين او ضعفين
قد يكون بين 800 وبين 900 مليون دولار
تقييم يعني حول
وهذا يمكن يعني
يفكرون فيه كثير من المستثمرين لما يجوني
الشركه قبل طرح العام اللي ممكن تجيبه
ويسارعون النمو وقتها لاحقا بس هي هي فعلا
علامه استفهام في التوزيع الجغرافي ابو
عبد العزيز السعوديه خمسين في الميه
الامارات 15% تقريبا الثلث وهي الثلث عدد
السكان فشفت يعني منطقيه بالتحليل سطحي
لكن شوف قطر
اعلى تقريبا 20% والكويت على الرغم قطر
عاليه كانت والكويت كانت يعني اقل مما
تصورت هي الشركه بدات في الكويت والان
الكويت تقريبا سبعه في المئه يعني شركه
كويتيه المنشا ولكن ليست كويتيه العمليات
يعني اذا صحت صح التعبير وهذا يذكرني
صراحه يعني في هذه القطاعات اللي معتمده
على التوسع الجغرافي واللي ما هي ما فيها
اعتماد على التقنيه بشكل كبير وانما في
اعتماد يعني بشكل كبير على موضوع التسويق
وكفاءه
يعني
ديناميكيه التسويق جوا الشركه احيانا اذا
حظيت بفريق قوي في دوله معينه يقدر يؤدي
اداء مبهر يعني صراحه انا ما اعرف مين
عندهم ما شاء الله ماسك قطر لكن هذا ترفع
له القبعه على انه كون انك انت في قطر
تحقق يعني
تقريبا 40% من مبيعات السعوديه
ففعلا يعني انجاز
سهل للفريق انه يعني عدد السكان القوه
الشرائيه كثير من العوامل ليست في صالح
يعني يسوق القطري
فيعني هذا يمكن التحدي دائما في التوسع في
هذه الاسواق في تفسير اخر مو بضروره
يتعارض مع انه الفريق اللي قطر قد يكون
فعلا قوي لكن يخليني افكر بتنافسيه فلور
لانه احنا عارفين الامارات فيها اكثر من
لاعب هناك جوي وغيرهم
فهل هذا يعني
في السوق الاماراتي السبب يعني
كفاءه وقوه الفريق اللي هناك ولا جزء منها
يعني ينم عن نقاط تحتاج تحسين في تنافسيه
فلور لاحقا بس كيف تفسر 20% من قطر انا
كيف تفسرها لان اتخيل عدد المنافسين في
الامارات اكثر من قطر
فبالتالي رغم من السوق الاماراتي اكبر
الا انه ما قدر يحصل الحصه اللي يحص قطر
لعدد يمكن المنافسين يتواجدهم اقل من
الامارات انا اتفق معاك سوق الاماراتي بلا
شك هو الانضج خصوصا في هذا القطاع يعني
اتذكر يمكن حتى قبل 12 سنه كان يمديك تطلب
ورود اونلاين وتدفع قيمتها اونلاين سواء
في دبي ولا في المدن الاخرى فاكيد نضج
القطاع ونضج السوق يلعب دورس ويجعل
التنافسيتك صعبه اتفق تماما
ويمكن يمكن هذه الفجوه اللي موجوده في قطر
يمكن ما كان عندهم البنيه التحتيه الكافيه
فصار يعني نجاح كبير مثل ما شفنا في
السعوديه يعني الحق يقال ان الشركه قدرت
تخلط
وشم او علامه تجاريه قويه جدا يعني خلينا
نقول صاروا قريبين من انهم يكونون نحوس
هولد نيم يعني في في السعوديه بلا شك
ونشاطهم في عمليه التسويق ونشاطهم في
رعايه الحفلات ويع
الرعايات اللي يسوونها للكثير من المشاهير
وغيرها بلا شك انها اتت يعني
ثمارها من ناحيه خلق وسم يعتبر مميز
ورفيعي الى حد ما في المنظومه يمكن نقطه
ثانيه في الملف انه معدل اعاده الشراء عند
العملات تقريبا اثنين وربع
للعميل الواحد
يمكن هنا في فرصه انها يعني من خلال
التنويع المنتجات اللي موجوده عند فلورد
انه يقدر يحصل قيمه اعلى من نفس العميل
اللي موجود عنده
فبالتالي جزء من النمو مو لازم يكون توسع
جغرافي بن نتوسع بالمنتجات
ونتوسع في حصه الشركه من محفظه العميل
اللي موجوده
[موسيقى]
من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه
الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفاء للاستثمار المزيد
في وصف الحلقه
[موسيقى]
ودي صراحه اتكلم عن يعني نسبه الربحيه
وبعدين ممكن نروح للمؤشرات الاخرى اللي هو
الجروس مورجن يعني او ما يعرف بالتيكريت
النسبه اللي تاخذها الشركه من كل طلب
بعد احتساب التكاليف المباشره المرتبطه
بالطلب في عام 2021 كانت تقريبا 33% وفي
عام 29 22 كانت 39% ففي تحسن واضح يعني
قرابه 25% تقريبا في نسبه الربحيه وهذا
مؤشر شفت انه ايجابي جدا وعندهم تطلعات
انها تزيد مع الوقت بحيث انها توصل 45
ويمكن حتى 47% لكن في توضيح هنا مهم ويمكن
انت ذكرت حتى شركه جويفت ففي توضيح اعتقد
انه مهم عن فلويد والنموذج عملها
وسبق يعني احنا في الموسم الاول تكلمنا عن
ف باسهاب فالمهتم ممكن حتى يبحث عن الحلقه
ويسمع يعني
تحليلنا للشركه بشكل عام والسوق اللي تعمل
فيه لكن بالنسبه لنموذج العمل فهم معتمدين
على ما يعرف
بالانسورس
لسلسله القيمه بالكامل يعني وصلوا الى
انهم يستوردون الورود مباشره يعني حتى هو
ما يشتري من سوق الجمله بل حتى في بعض
الاحيان يشتري من المزارع بشكل مباشر
فبالتالي هو يملك سلسله القيمه بالكامل
بالاضافه الى عمليه التوصيل يعني الى حد
قريب كان عندهم سياراتهم الخاصه وسائقينهم
صح انه ممكن يستاجرونها
بمدى طويل وغيرها لكن هم يديرون السلسله
بالكامل فانا شخصيا كنت اتوقع ان نسبه
الربحيه او الجراس مورين راح تكون اعلى
بكثير لان المعروف انه في مجال الورود
انه يعني اذا رحت محل
تكون بحدود الثمانين في المئه طبعا عندك
تكاليف خفيه زي
التوالف واجار المحل وغيرها من الاشياء
لكن في نفس العمليه الورود نفسها تصل الى
80 احيانا حتى 90% نسبه الربحيه
فاستغربت صراحه وجود 33 طبعا انا عزتها
الى تكاليف التسويق بها شكل تكاليف تسويق
المباشر داخله اعتقد بالاضافه طبعا الى
تكاليف التوصيل انت لما يكون عندك اسطول
وتوفير السريع بشكل عام كذلك توصيل جيد
يعني نفس اليوم اليوم التالي صحيح مو سهل
هنا يعني ايضا نشوف ظهور في الملف لموضوع
السحورات من دماجات يعني يتوقعون 23 ترتفع
الربحيه تصير ايجابيه 6% والسنه اللي
بعدها توصل ل 13% وجز كبير من الربحيه هذه
جايه بفضل الاستحواذات اللي هم يعتقدون
يعني راح تضيف
للايراد وراح يعني تدعم الربحيه
يمكن الورود لحالها فعلا صعب انها تكون
كافيه لتنميه الربحيه ويظل السؤال طيب
بالنسبه
لشركه في تجاره الكترونيه او شركه ناويه
يعني في السوق وشرب حي المناسبه لهذا اللي
تدخل فيها السوق انا شفت يمكن
13% يعني رقم عالي جدا لكن بنفس الوقت
اشوفه رقم مقبول طالما نشوف ايش ممكن يصير
في السنتين والثلاثه اللي بعدها طالما انه
يقدرون يقنعوني المستثمرين في البورصه
العامه انه هامش التحسين في الربحيه ما
زال موجود انه مو بهذا نهايه التحسينات
الممكنه هنا نقطه مهمه انه يعني انا ذكرت
انه في عام 2021 نسبه الربحيه كانت 33
طبعا المقصد الربحيه الربح الصافي وانما
اقصد ربحيه يعني المبيعات
33% هو 22 39% والملاحظ انه في عام 22
فلفل مبيعات كانت من منتجات ليست بورود
مما يعني ان ارتفاع
الربحيه حق الشركه قاعد يجي من المنتجات
غير الورد مما يدل انه قد يكون القطاع
نفسه يعني ما هو يعني
المجزي او المربح بشكل كبير وهذا يؤكد
استراتيجيه
الشركه ان ودهم يتوسعون الى القطاعات
الاخرى وطبعا اسهل طريقه للتوسع زي ما
ذكرت هو موضوع
الاستحوذت لكن في هنا نقطه مهمه اللي هي
موضوع الربحيه او الربح الصافي فالشركه في
عام 2021 خسرت 14 مليون دولار تقريبا 15%
من المبيعات و2022 قللت خسارتها الى عشره
مليون دولار
وهو سبعه في المئه من المبيعات رغم
الزياده في موضوع الصرف على التسويق فهذه
نقطه ايجابيه يعني تحسب لهم بشكل عام انه
في كفاءه
لحد ما تشغيليه بالاضافه لكفاءه في عمليه
اداره يعني التسويق يعني انك انت ترفع
الربحيه وترفع مصاريفك التسويقيه وتزيد
مبيعاتك
فعندك يعني معادله يبدو انها تعمل بشكل
جيد هو هنا هنا نقطه مره مهمه كمان انه هل
وصلت فلور الى حجم من قاعده العملاء اللي
يسمح لها انها تحول من استراتيجيه التسويق
حقته من عمليه استحواذ التركيز بشكل اساسي
على استحواذ على العمله جدد الى ان
التسويق يركز بشكل اساسي على استبقاء
العملاء الحاليين وبالتالي نزيد القيمه او
الال تي في او القيمه الكليه للعملاء اللي
موجودين هنا فنعم راح ترتفع ارقام التسويق
لكنها كنسبه من المبيعات وهذا موجود ايضا
في الملف قاعده تقل كنسبه خلال سنتين
الجايه فهذه فرضيه كبيره لو تحققت بتساهم
في النمو اللي قاعدين نشوفه بالربحيه
احد اول يعني المؤشرات ان الفرضيه بطريقه
سليمه وتحسن معدل التسرب او التيرن كان في
تقريبا ونزل الى 62% العام الماضي كان
افضل في عام 2021 لكن يظل التحسن من 75
الى 62 تحسن ملحوظ جدا
مع بقاء
العملاء يعني يا انهم قاعدين يسوقون
لشريحه
اكثر تركيزا قاعدين يحاولون عملاء اكثر
يعني حاجه او اكثر
استمتاعنا وحاجه للمنتج او انهم قاعدين
يحسنون من التجربه تجربه العميل نفسها
ويخلون العملاء يستمرون معاهم وهذا المعدل
قد يبدو عالي لكنه افضل من كثير من
الشركات في هذا المجال مجال الهدايا
طيب يعني واحده من البنش ماركس او خليني
اقول لك المعايير اللي انا شفتها اللي فئه
الهدايا المناسبات كانت تكلمون عن نسب
تسرب 80% وفوق يعني ستين بالمئه تعتبر
فعلا مميزه هنا طبعا انا اتفهم يعني سبب
ارتفاع نسبه التسرب واللي هي بطبيعه الحال
انت اذا توهقت تبغى تشتري هديه لصديق او
قريب في مناسبه خاصه اكيد راح تبحث عن حل
وحيطلع لك كاحد ابرز واهم وافضل الحلول
فعليا اللي موجوده لكن بعد ما تطلب طلبيتك
الاولى
بطبيعه الحال ما راح ترجع تستخدمها الا في
المناسبه القادمه اللي يمكن ما تكون يعني
قريبه جدا
نسبه التسرب مفهومه لان هذا السوق
ما هو بالسوق اللي مثلا لو ننتقل جاهز
مثلا جاهز ومعدل طلبات العميل للشهر
الواحد خمس او ست طلبات لانك انت تحتاج ت
عده مرات في اليوم ففي فرص عاليه انك ترجع
تستخدم المنتج في اكثر من مره نفس الشيء
مع كريم تحتاج تتنقل اكثر من مره وغيرهم
من الشركات اللي فعلا فيها استخدام عالي
لكن لما نتكلم عن شركه مثل ما قلنا هي
الفيتامين
والدواء يعني انت ما عندك استخدام شهري
والله راح يعني تهدي عده مرات او حتى
سنويا وهذا يظهر في الاوردر ريت حقهم او
اللي هو معدل اعاده طلبات عند العملاء زي
ما ذكرت وليد هو اثنين وربع يعني مرتين
وربع مره في يبدو لي انه في السنه طبعا هم
ما وضحوا لكن بناء على الارقام يبدو انه
في السنه فنتفهم هذا الشيء لكن اللي اللي
غير متفهم بالنسبه لي
انا اتقبل نسبه التسرب اذا كانت اذا كان
سعر الاستحواذ على العميل قليل او او
منطقي او حتى في افضل الاحوال يعتمد على
الاورجانيك
البحث العضوي او
يعتمد على ما يعرف بالتوصيه توصيه
الاصدقاء وغيرهم خصوصا ان المنتج فعلا
اثبت كفاءته وجودته لكن قاعدين نشوف سعر
استحواذ على العملاء قاعد يزداد مع الوقت
وصلوا العام
82 دولار تقريبا والعامل الماضي كان 78
دولار ففي زياده وان كانت طفيفه ولكن في
زياده في التكلفه يعني انا سويت حسبه
بسيطه
الشركه تحتاج على اساس انها تسترجع تكلفه
الاستحواذ ان كل عميل يتم الاستحواذ عليه
انه يطلب مرتين لان على نسبه الربحيه
حقتها اللي هي 40% من كل طلب
مضروبه بمرتين وربع اللي هو معدل اعاده
شراء العميل الواحد راح تقدر تسترجع 86
دولار من العميل الواحد واللي هي قريبه
جدا من نقطه او سعر استحواذ الامير اللي
هو 82 دولار فصراحه انا بالنسبه لي كانت
هذه الاشكاليه
الكبيره ان اول شيء ارتفاع السعر وانا
اتفهم طبعا السعر ليش مرتفع لكن بنفس
الوقت السعر قاعد يزيد مو قاعد ينزل
واللي المفروض مع الوقت انك انت تزيد
كفاءتك
وتقل تكلفه الاستحواذ طبعا الطريقه
الثانيه لمواجهه الاشكاليه هذه او التحدي
انه ترفع القيمه الكليه للعميل للال تي في
تحاول ترفع عدد الطلبات اللي قاعد يجي منه
حجم السله ويمكن هذا سبب من اسباب تركيزهم
على تمحور التسويق حول استبقاء خلال
السنتين الجايه انا ما ادري اذا شفتوها او
انها فاتتني انا لكن ما لاحظت اي كلام عن
فئه الاعمال يعني مثلا منصه رساله في
السعوديه يعني في الاخير عملت تحول الى
البي تو بي وتجنبت مشكله
قله عدد الطلبات اللي تجي من عميل الواحد
فهل فلور عملت الشيء هذا وعنده هنيه انا
ما شفتها صراحه بالملف يمكنها فاتتني انا
كذلك ما انتبهت لها بالعكس ارجع لنقطه
سابقه قلتها وليد اللي هي حسيت المرحله
العمريه محدده بشكل كبير يعني من 20 الى
فما شفت الاعمال وكذلك حسيت المرحله
العمريه المستهدفه ضيقه مع انهم عندهم
بيانات يعني اكيد شافوا الموضوع هذا لكن
حسيت فيه الى اربعين خمس واربعين بالعكس
يمكن يكون فيه مناسبات الولد الثاني الولد
الولاده التخرج مدري ايش يعني يكون فيها
اسباب اخرى مختلفه لاستخدام
نقطه على نقطه الشراء مرتين بس اربطها
كذلك في فكره الاستحواذات والربحيه اللي
قاعد تجي من المنتجات الاخرى لانها بتقلل
كذلك معدل عدد المرات الشراء عشان تقدر
ترجع
تكلفه الاستحواذ العميل فيعني لما نشوف
التوقعات المستقبليه وليد بس افصل النقطه
اللي قلتها قبل شوي تقريبا متوقع في 2024
ثلث الايرادات تكون من الاستحواذات لكن
نصف الارباح
فواضح انه التوسع مو بس بالورد كخيار لكن
كحاجه لزياده الربحيه في الشركه ويعني
فعلا النقاط اللي انا ذكرتها سابقا على
تكلفه الاستحواذ تجعلني اتساءل ان متى راح
يكون العميل مدرا يعني للارباح بالنسبه
للشركه وانا اعتقد ان يعني للاسف البيانات
هذه مين عندنا لكن اعتقد ان الشركه هذه
عندها يعني كتله جيده من العملاء المديرين
الارباح بمعنى يمكن من عشره الى 20% من
عملاء الشركه هم يستخدمون المنتج
بظني يعني من خمسه الى عشر مرات في السنه
الواحده وبينما جزء كبير من العملاء
يستخدمون المنتج مره واحده وهذا دوري اللي
قاعدين يرفعون تكلفه الاستحواذ وقاعدين
يقللون من نسبه الربحيه للشركه لكن بنفس
الوقت انت صعب انك تركز بس على العملاء
هذول اللي يعرفون
او العملاء الاكثر فعاليه معاك لانه وقتها
راح تقل مبيعاتك وانت تحتاج انك توري
النمو للمستثمرين بعتقد هذه المعضله اللي
امام الشركه بلا شك هما قدروا انهم
يستحوذون على جزء من السوق جزء من الناس
اللي صار عندهم ولاء عالي واستخدام عالي
لكن التحدي او السؤال كم اعداد هؤلاء
الاوفياء اللي يستخدمون الخدمه يعني اكثر
من ثلاثه الى اربع مرات في السنه وهل
يقدرون فعلا يوسعون هذه القاعده
من غير ما انك انت تضطر انك تستحوذ على
اغلب الناس لانه
يعني هل في طريقه يقدرون فيها انهم يوصلون
لهؤلاء العملاء بتكلفه منطقيه من غير ما
انهم والله احتاج كل احد يحمل التطبيق
ويجرب ويسجل على اساس اني انا اقدر افلتر
العمله انا برايي هذا هو السؤال والتحدي
الحقيقي امام الشركه اعتقد نقطه زياده عدد
الطلبات
على قاعده كبيره من العملاء تقريبا قرابه
المليون عميل يعني شيء جدا جدا صعب خصوصا
زي ما ذكرت انه
الغالبيه يحتاجك فيه لحظه معينه في ازمه
معينه ويتجاوزك لكن
يعني كيف تقدر انك
[موسيقى]
صحيح انك لو دخلت في
البخور والاشياء الهدايا الاخرى راح توسع
او ممكن تحاول انك توسع عدد الطلبات
لكن
ارجع واقول يعني مشكله انك كل ما حاولت
انك توصل لعملاء اكثر هو الصرف الزائد على
التسويق والصرف الزائد هذا اذا ما قدرت
انك تسترجع بسرعه
ارقام الشركه في السنوات القادمه لن تكون
يعني ايجابيه او على الاقل مثل ما هم
يطمحون لها احنا وصلنا الى هذا الجزء من
النقاش
واتوقع نحتاج كمان نتكلم عن عبد العزيز
اللوغاني يعني الفريق التنفيذي اللي مسؤول
عن الشركه اللي بيجاوب الاسئله هذه اللي
قاعده تطلع من المستثمرين عبد العزيز يعني
لما تكلمنا عن هنقرستيشن وطلبات اصلا كان
من الناس الاوائل اللي
مسكوا دف الطلبات في فتره من الفترات ايضا
من مؤسسين
فيت كابيتال ويا جهه استثماريه
فاذا طالعها من المنظور الفريق التنفيذي
يعطيك نوع من الطمعانين انه طيب في ناس
هنا عندهم خبره انهم يواجهون المصائب ايضا
محمد عريفي هنا المسؤول عن السوق السعودي
كان اداء ممتاز ايضا في الموضوع
فاتخيل يعني صحن
الملف هنا صعب نوعا ما لكن المستثمرين راح
يناظرون الفريق اللي ماسك الملف وراح
ينفذه هل هو فعلا الفريق المناسب له ولا
لا والى الان يعني اشوف احداث كثيره
للتفاؤل بالعمه زي ما تكلمنا فيهم بالحلقه
الموسم الاول يعني كانهم اخترعوا
جانب او نوع من التجاره الالكترونيه في
المنطقه
يعني الله يقويهم
ونتمنى لهم احيا وقطاع ميت يعني ما شاء
الله عليهم يعني حتى ارقام
استيرادات الخليج ككل يعني عام 2019 ذكرنا
هذا الرقم سابقا من الورود يعني كان رقم
طفيف جدا رقم بسيط جدا وكان توقعنا انه هم
يمكن ضاعفوا السوق اكثر من مره من خلال
اعاده التموضع يعني الورد
فاعل رئيسي في المناسبات الخاصه والعامه
بلا شك هم عادوا اختراع او هيكله سوق كامل
لكن بلا شك انه في تحديات وزي ما ذكرتم
يعني الله يقويهم عبد العزيز ومحمد
نتمنى لهم كل التوفيق بنروح لاعلان ثاني
من اعلانات
ليب 23 اللي هو نعناع شركه اخرى تجمع جوله
كبيره من الجوله جيم راس راند سي او سيران
جمعت 133 مليون دولار بس شفنا مستثمرين
كذلك متنوعين في شركه المملكه القابضه
شركه السلطان يونيفرس شركه الجماز القابضه
دلت البركه
واضح انهم وصلوا مرحله يروحون يتكلمون مع
مستثمرين يمكن بعضهم متعود على شركات
الراسمال الجريء لكن بعضهم مكاتب عائليه
وشركات قابضه يمكن مو كل يوم تستثمر بشركه
ناشئه لكن يبدو ان وضحوا لهم الفرصه
وشافوا الفرصه المناسبه سنوات القادمه
الحلوه المؤسس رئيس لنعناع وسالته يعني
حتى
على الموضوع ذكر لي حاجتين مهمه يعني
ملفته هنا الحاجه الاولى انه هذه الجوله
ملكيه خاصه ما فيها دين الشغله الثانيه
انه يعني هي وسرقه فلاورد دليل على شهيه
هذه النوعيه من المستثمرين اللي يجون قبل
الطرح ومستثمرين استراتيجيين يعني اقرب ما
يكون للملكيه خاصه من اهل الاستثمار الجري
اللي ما يسمى باعمال اللي تستهلك راس مع
العالي كابتنسيب
يعني طلوع خبر جولتين وقت متقارب كان فعلا
اشاره الى وجودها الشهيه اللي كان كثير من
الناس يتوقعون
يمكن خلال سنتين الماضيه لكن واضح على
القلب المنظومه المحليه لانها موجوده
ومستمره كمان طبعا انتشرت على اطار سامي
انتشرت صوره لسامي مع الوليد بن طلال وهذا
ذكرني صراحه يعني بالمملكه القابضه وهم ما
هم غريبين على هذه الساحه ابدا يعني
في عام 2010 تقريبا كان من اهم المستثمرين
في تويتر وهو اللي عزز لايلون ماسك لما
قال باخذ الشركه بشكل خاص وقال له انا
معاك لكن ايضا هو كان احد اهم المستثمرين
في شركه لفت وبعدها ايضا في كريم في
جولتهم من طراز سي لما كانت الجوله
الملياريه اللي صنعت اليونيكون وايضا شركه
ديزر يمكن في العديد من الشركات خصوصا
طبعا في في اوروبا لكن يعني صراحه نشاط
جيد وخصوصا اذا يعني سوي
وتذكرنا انه المملكه القابضه
حصلت على استثمار او على شراء حصص من قبل
صندوق الاستثمارات العامه فالان يعني قد
نرى تنافس ما بينهم وما بين سنابل في
الدخول في هذا النوع من الجولات المتاخره
ممتاز بالعكس
الصحيه هذه انت ذكرت كريم لما شفت انا
جدول المستثمرين في الجوله اللي تمت سنه
21 في نعناع كريم كانت مشاركه فيها فحسيت
انه مثير الانتباه وما ادري اذا لها علاقه
برغبه كريم في موضوع السوبر اب ولا كان
الهدف شيء اخر انا
يعني بدات سنه 2023 كنت اقول المنظومه في
السعوديه خصوصا السنه الماضيه نمت لكن هل
نشوف نمو ان شاء الله مشابه ولا اكبر في
سنه 23 لكن كنت حاطي يعني يدي على قلبي
قاعد اقول ان شاء الله ما تكون جولات بس
جت
مدفوعه بالنصف الاول من 22 لكن الصفقتين
هذول لحالهم نعناع وفلاور يعني يوضحون لك
حسب كيف تبغى تعد فلاورد بس عشان اكون
واضح لكن حتى لو اخذنا الحاله هذه 13 14%
من استثمارات العامل الماضي او 25 اذا
حسب كيف تبي تحسب
فيعني ان شاء الله انه بدايه قويه ونشوف
دعم او يعني تواجد كبير للاستثمار هذه
السنه كذلك خصوصا انه في شركات كثيره حصلت
على جولات الف او الجولات سميت بالبدره
لكن كانت جولات كبيره خلال 18 شهر الماضيه
فجولاتهم القادمه ممكن تكون السنه هذه او
بدايه 24
[موسيقى]
طبعا هنا يتضح يعني يعني ان في فرق ما بين
مثلا
الاهداف من يعني خلف استثمار الاموال في
فلوج
وانعناع لان فلاود واضح انها شركه مو
قاعده تحرق كثير وان كانت تعمل في قطاع
يستنزف فالكثير من رؤوس الاموال لانهم هم
زي ما ذكرت يديرون سلسله بالكامل لكن يبدو
انه يعني هم تحت السيطره خساره في عام
واحد العام الماضي عشره مليون دولار بمعدل
حرق شهري يعني يقول قرابه ال800 الف دولار
هذا يعتبر شيء يعني
جدا سهل وهين والمبلغ اللي اخذوه كبير جدا
مقارنه
بالمدرج اللي يحتاجونه خصوصا انهم
يستهدفون الربحيه في العام القادم لكن
اعتقد نعناع قصتها مختلفه تماما نعناع من
الشركات اللي سوت ما يعرف به او عمليه
التحور في نموذج الاعمال لو تذكرون كانوا
يشتغلون في
مع السوبر ماركت بحيث انك تطلب من السوبر
ماركت ويكون في موظفين في السوبر ماركت
جاهزون الطلب بعدين يجي مندوب منعناع ياخذ
الطلب ويودي لك اياه وهذا الموديل صعب جدا
ويمكن
تكمن صعوبته في صعوبه يعني
انك تتعامل معاه حقنا السوبر ماركت من
ناحيه تنظيمهم للعمليات وتنظيمهم يعني
سرعه هذا وطبعا موضوع اللي هو
اداره المخزونات يعني كثير من السوبر
ماركت حسب ما اذكرني طلعت شوي على هذا
القطاع ما يدري يعني ما يدري وش المخزون
اللي موجود في المتجر الان لان الانظمه
اللي يعملون عليها انظمه قديمه جدا
تسوي دبلومنت او يعني
فرز للمخزون في نهايه اليوم فاثناء اليوم
لو خلص منتج معين ما يدرون عشان كذا لو
تذكرون التجربه السابقه مع نعناع وغيرها
من تطبيقات لما يروح السوبر ماركت يقول لك
نص الطلبات ما هي موجوده لان فكان هذا
يعني مشكله كبيره وتحدي كبير عندهم فبعدها
قرروا التحول الى الاعتماد الذاتي يعني ما
يحك ظهرك الا ما يحق جلدك ظفرك
وسووا مجموعه من المتاجر السوداء او
الدارك ستوريز واللي فيها يقدمون عدد
محدود من المنتجات لكن يقدرون يوصلونها
بسرعه عاليه والوعد حقهم هو عشرين دقيقه
وفي انباء انهم فتحوا اكثر من عشرين متجر
اسود وهذا يقودني
للمنافسين يعني السوق هذا سوق في منافسين
يعني بشكل غير طبيعي عندك طبعا عندهم ما
يعرف
كريم واللي ناويه تدخل عندك جاهز اللي
دخلت على بك يمكن ما دخلوا في المتاجر
السوداء بشكل مباشر لكن بشكل غير مباشر
وايضا عندك شركه نينجا واللي اسسها
ابراهيم الجاسم المؤسس السابق لهنقرستيشن
واللي حسب الانباء الغير معلنه انه جمع
عشرين مليون دولار
في محاوله لاختراق هذا القطاع الواعد
فيعني اعتقد انه استخدام القطاع الواعد
القطاع الواعد هنا لكن عالميا يمكن تكلمنا
بدايه السنه الماضيه كان في اغلاقات وكان
في تحديات على نموذج الاعمال هذا وعد
الربع ساعه والعشرين دقيقه بلا شك يعني
قطعتك بس المفارقه
عالميا شفنا في امريكا اكثر من شركه افلست
واقفلت عملياتها مثل شركه
جو باف وغيرها في اوروبا شفنا يعني اندماج
ما بين جيتر وما بين غوريلا واشترتها يعني
ارخص الاسعار في وقت ما قدرت انها تاخذ اي
استثمار
محليا شفنا
باكستان واللي جمع الجولبي من طراز باء
يعني اكثر من 85 مليون دولار اعلنت
افلاسها واقفلت تماما عندنا في مصر شركه
اسمها رابط تستثمر فيها رائد والعديد من
الصناديق المحليه يعني موجودين في القطاع
ما ندري وش صاير عليهم بالضبط في القطاع
في العديد من اللاعبين هو مغري لان حجم
السوق مغري جدا يعني
نعناع تقول ان حجم السوق هذا في المنطقه
160 مليار دولار هذا تصريحنا انا في
السعوديه يقول لك ان البقالات والسوبر
ماركت مبيعاتها توصل الى 80 90 مليار
دولار في السنه فاحنا نتكلم عن سوق ضخم
جدا وهذا سبب الاهتمام فيه لكن ايضا
الربحيه فيه عليه نقطه تساؤل كبيره هو
فيها نقطه لا شك لكن لما اتكلم مع كثير من
الناس اللي بالسوق الرد اللي انا اسمعه
كثير انه المنطقه بدات الخليج مختلفه لانه
هي من مناطق القليله في العالم اللي القوه
الشرائيه كبيره جدا ثلاثه اضعاف الشرائيه
للفرد يمكن بالمعدل العالمي
وقوه وتكلفه العماله يعني تكاد تكون مثل
الدول النام
فبالتالي يجتمعوا حاجتين قوه شراء وقله
تكاليف من ناحيه اللي يمكن تخلي الاسواق
الخليج مختلفه هذه الحجه اللي انا اسمعها
كثير ويمكن نشوف عاد
مدى صحتها خلال فتره الجايه عاد يعني
اسبوع حافر ابو عبد العزيز
خصوصا على مستوى الصناديق جدا الباروده
الجاف قاعد يتراكم ما شاء الله وعندنا
ثلاث روافد اساسيه يعني شفناها خلال
الاسبوع الماضي الرافد الاول شفنا اعلانات
لصناديق جريئه متخصصه في استثمار رسمان
الجريه اس تي بي اطلقت استراتيجيه توتل
جروث ملكيه ودين امباكت صندوق 133 مليون
دولار كذلك شفنا مجموعه من الصناديق
الصغيره اللي بين العشرين وال 35 مليون
دولار منها واحد من الصناديق اسمه
بلانيتري متخصص بالفضاء فكان ملف
التخصص الفيرتكل هذا يعني سبق لنا شفنا
صناديق متخصصه بالتقنيه الماليه اليوم
نشوف الفضاء هل هذا بدايه لمزيد من
الصناديق المتخصصه خلال الفتره الجايه قد
قد يكون يعني شاهد العام الرافد الثاني
وكان اتكلمنا عنه اسبوع الماضي بس اليوم
شفنا اعلانات اللي هو
وصول الشركات زي نعناع وغيرهم الى مراحل
متاخره يعني
مثير للمستثمرين من
الاصول الثانيه الملكيه الخاصه
واستراتيجيين وغيرهم او المستخدمين يبغون
يدخنون ما قبل الاكتتاب وهذا يتيح للشركات
هذه حلول تمويليه ما تطره من ويبيع ملكيه
ممكن يقترضون من خلال بنشر دات او ال ال
الدين الجديد فشفنا اعلان من اس تي بي
اللي يتكلم عن توتال جرو كنت تتكلم احسان
جواد في اس تي في يقول هذه استراتيجيه هم
وضعوها المسلمين معاهم بمبلغ مقداره 150
مليون دولار اتهلوا انه يتعاملون يعني ما
نقول الطيف واسع من الخيارات ممكن
المستثمر يقول انا ابغى يكون عندي تغطيه
على المراحل المتاخره من خلال
استثمارات النمو او من خلال الاقراض الجري
اول مراحل اللي قبلها من خلال الاستثمارات
راس المال وبالتالي يعطونهم تغطيه اوسع من
الناحيه هذه ايضا شفنا شروق
مخصص لدينا جريء في السعوديه 100 مليون
دولار
فبالتالي ايضا شفنا ميراك اعلنوا صندوق
اخر لحلول التمويليه للشركات التقنيه مو
بس الشركات
الرياديه في الجانب هذا وشفنا ايضا البنوك
ما تبغى يعني تترك لحالها بنك الرياض حط
مليار دولار
لبرامج للشركات في قطاع التقنيه بنك
الفرنسي نفس المبلغ مليار دولار كذلك في
نفس الاستراتيجيه والرافد الثالث هنا
والاخير لكنه يمكن اكبرهم هو رافد
استثمارات استراتيجيه شفنا ارامكو اعلنه
تكبير الصندوق حقهم وعد من 200 مليون الى
500 مليون دولار بهدف توطين التقنيه وشفنا
استثمار مؤخرا لهم في شركه يابانيه واحده
من اهدافها انها يعني تبدا تنتقل او على
الاقل تاسس لعمل وتطوير في السعوديه شفنا
شركه اتصالات السعوديه اسسوا صندوق او
الصندوق المؤسساتي للاستثمار لكن للاسف ما
اعلن الرقم فما نعرف اكثر شيء هذا كان
اكثر شيء مخيب للعمال صراحه ما اعلنوا
لانه فعلا يعني الصلاه السعوديه اللي
عاجبني في تجربتهم مع الاستثمار الجريء ان
هذه ثالث تجربه لهم يعني هم كانوا في عام
اعتقد 2010 2011 اطلقوا اول صندوق وكان
وقتها صندوق فعلا فعلا جريء بحجمه
اهدافه يعني نتكلم عن عام 2010 2011 100
مليون دولار مبلغ استثنائي خمسين ودخله
كريم اول
كريم نعم وبعدين توجهوا 500 مليون دولار
لو كان جريء بشكل اضافي انه الجو قالوا
طيب حنا مو متعودين على هذا النوع من
الاستثمار وجابوا شركه شركه راس مالجري
فرنسيه قالوا اديروا لنا هالصندوق فكان
يعني حتى ما قالوا خلينا نشوف ايش السالفه
قالوا خلينا نجيب واحد يعرف هذا القطاع
وخليه يذكر بالخير ايمن العتيق يعني كان
هو اللي يدير صندوق المنطقه ويعني ما شاء
الله عليه هو يمكن اللي وضع لبنه الاساس
يعني
فشفنا هذا النوع من التوجه اللي هو يعني
اسناد الصندوق لجهه اخرى بعدين شفنا انهم
دخلوا
كمستثمر ووحيد وهذا شيء نادر انك تشوفه في
عالم الصنادي الجريئه دخلوا مع اس تي في
في صندوق 500 مليون دولار والان نشوفهم
يشمرون عن سوائدهم بعد ما ندري هم متاخرين
ولا لا وهل بيؤدون ولا لا لكن
يسوون صندوق خاص فيهم وهذا الشيء صراحه
يعني دخول هذه الشركه لهذا القطاع هو اكثر
خبر انا شفته ايجابي لان لا نتكلم على
قدره للوصول ولا نتكلم على
قاعده عملاء ولا نتكلم حتى على عمق تقني
موجود عند الشركه مقارنه بالبنوك وغيرها
بصراحه من اكثر الاخبار اللي حمستني من
ناحيه الصناديق هل كان واضح اللي هو
صندوق الاستثمار
بالقطاعات المجاوره لنشاط الشركه الام ولا
صندوق راس مال جري مستقل لكن تملك الشركه
انا ما كان واضح لي من اللي فهمته انا انه
هذا الصندوق يعني صندوق استثمار مؤسساتي
داخل اتصالات نفسها بل انه في جزء من فريق
السابق في انس باريو المسرع المعروفه
انتقل الى
السيايف ضمنهم
اسم معروف في المنظومه الرياضيه الاخ
السعودي هواوي الان هو جزء من الفريق وراح
يكون تركيزهم بالغالب على المراحل المبكره
وزي ما قلتم يعني الشركه عندها اصول كثيره
ممكن
تتميز فيها عن كثير من المستثمرين الاخرين
من ناحيه القيمه المضافه يمكن تساعد فيها
الشركه وكذلك عندها خبره يعني غشيمه تدخل
ويمكن تخرب على بعض الشركات انه لانه ما
عندها خبره سابقه فهذه كانت يعني شركه
اتصالات لكن على نفس الرافد الثالث كان
فيه ايضا شركه كبيره
فيها يعني او خلينا نقول الصندوق اسس تحت
اسم ايده باليوتيوب اريبيا وهذا الصندوق
مؤسس من علي بابا الصينيه وايضا صندوق
استمارات السعوديه وشركه الاتصالات عام
2019 كان عندهم 400 مليون دولار الان في
بلنبرغ صرحوا انهم قربوا يقفلون المليار
دولار جديده لتركيز على سوق المنطقه وسوق
اسيا وكيف يبنون جسر بين السوق قد سمعنا
لهم عن اي استثمارات في المنطقه اشهر يعني
هو يعتمد على تعريفه للاستثمار بس
كنت اتكلم معهم ايضا الاسبوع الماضي فيك
عدد من الشركات الصينيه اللي جات للمملكه
كانت من ضمن استثمارات لهم وايضا لهم
استثمار كبير جدا اللي هو عملوه مع اس تي
سي في الكلاود اس تي سي علي بابا كلاود هو
من استثمارات
وحتى صرحوا في مقاله بلومبرج انهم يخططون
لطرح ثلاث شركات في البورصه السعوديه قريب
انا تخميني انه هذه شركه الكلاود لابد
تكون واحده منها لانه بدينا نشوفهم يعني
ينجزون في عامل التش
فبالتالي منطقه جدا تكون ضمن الثلاثه
بتضيف معلومات مميزه السوق الكلاود ولا
السحابه اذا طرحت في السوق العام انا بس
تعليقي تعليق بسيط على نقطه
اس تي في صندوق
150 مليون دولار في اكثر من مكان ذكر انه
اغلاق اولي لكن في جوانب تركيز كبيره على
الدين والمراحل المتاخره فاتصور انه
الاغلاق النهائي حيكون صندوق اكبر بكثير
غير كذا بتكون عدد صفقات محدود جدا
لكن الاقراض كان اكبر مما تصورت الحماسه
والزخم للاقراض او الدين الجريء على الاقل
في اعلانات واحده
يصير بهذه السنه باقي السنه هذه يمكن بعض
الشركات ما تكون مبسوطه على التقييمات او
نزول التقييمات و يراهنون على 24 و 25
خلينا ناخذ دينجرري
اذا احتجنا لهذه السنه هو على موضوع
الاقراض يعني لاحظنا
لمسات للاعب جديد في السوق من الجهه
الحكوميه اللي هو برنامج الوطني لتطوير
قطاع التقنيه لانه كان هو اللي داخل مع اس
تي في
ايضا طلعوا مجموعه من المنتجات اللي حقيقه
مثيره للاهتمام وتوريك كيف السوق قاعد
يتشكل من ناحيه وش الخيرات اللي موجوده
وايش الاشياء اللي نحتاجها فمن ضمن
البرامج اللي طلعت من البرنامج
برنامج
انتقال مجموعه من الشركات نقلوا مقرهم الى
داخل السعوديه ايضا شفنا برامج تاهيل
لدخول المشاريع الكبيره الحكوميه ايضا
شفنا برامج اخرى قديمه يعملونها من ناحيه
يكمنون
المنظومه بالاشياء اللي مغطاه مي مغطاه من
قبل اس بي سي يوجد او منش او الجهات اخرى
مسؤوله عن الموضوع فواضح انه البارود جاف
هذا مرح يعني يستمر جاف لفتره طويله لكن
وين وكيف بيصير هذا اللي ودنا نشوفه خلال
الفتره الجايه طبعا لما تسوي يعني
لما تاخذ النظره بعيده شوي للمشهد الرياضي
التقني فعلا تشوف ان العديد من الجهات
بشكل مباشر وغير مباشر قاعده تصب في هذا
المكان وقاعد تكمل الحلقه هذه يعني لما
نتكلم على اس بي سي الشركه السعوديه لراس
المال الجري كيف انها بدت وساعدت
المستثمرين الملائكيين والصناديق وبعدين
توجهت الى صناديق الدين الجريء لما نشوف
جداء وكيفيه تمول الصناديق بشكل مباشر لما
نشوف سنابل وهي قاعده تقود الجولات
المتاخره
ولما نشوف زي ما ذكرت ان تي دي بي وبرامج
يعني تحفيز الشركات للانتقال في السعوديه
يعني اعطائهم تحفيزات وبعدين نشوف ايضا
منشات وبرنامج الشركات الملياريه بالتعاون
مع وزاره الاتصالات وغيرها فتلقى ان من كل
جهه قاعد يصير نوع من التحفيز والدعم
واللي قاعد يعني ينتج عنه اثر واضح واللي
فعلا محتاج في الفتره الحاليه ويمكن في
السنوات القادمه لين ما يصير عندنا قطاع
يعني مستقل ويمكن دكتور نبيل كوشك دايما
يقول انا اكثر لحظه اسعد فيها لما يجي
الصندوق يقول لي شكرا يا اس بي سي انا
محتاج فلوسك لان صار في اقبال وطلب
المستثمرين الخاصين وفعلا هذا هو الدور
الحقيقي اللي نتمناه التحفيز جيد لكن مع
الوقت ودك يصير القطاع متين وصلب وبحد
ذاته يعني
فعال وعنده كفاءه عاليه هي اقرب ما شبهها
زي البواجي يعني المفروض اذا تم التحفيز
واشتغل المحرك المنظومه تصير تعتمد على
نفسها لانه واحده من المخاوف اللي عندي
انا على الاقل كمستثمر انه وين الوزنيه
الصحيحه بين توزيع الدور بين اللاعبين
اللي موجوده من المنظومه والدعم اللي قاعد
يجي من الجهات الحكوميه دائما تخاف انه
يكون في نوع من التنافس غير المقصود بين
الاثنين او احيانا محفزات اللي قد تحفز
شيء لا يكون مناسب للسوق يعني شركات
المفروض انها تقفل بدري وتاخر تقفيله بسبب
وجود دعم المفروض انه ما استحقته وجيت في
الموضوع اللي يخليني اتفائل انه المنظومه
يعني بطرفينها بشقينها دائما في نقاشات
دائما في كلام بينهم ايضا موجود الجمعيه
السعوديه لراس المالك
الصناديق هذه كلها وتمثلهم تعطيهم ثقل في
نقاشهم مع الجهات الاخرى لعلنا نقدر نوصل
للوزن هذه بس هي من الاشياء اللي فعلا مره
حساسه ولازم ينتبه لها في جانب بناء
الشركات الجيده
ورواد الاعمال الممتازين اللي تكلمنا قبل
جوده رواد الاعمال والشركات تتحسن في عدد
من الاعلانات كذلك في ليبيا كانت ملفته
اكاديميات مثل اكاديميه متى
للمتبرز وكذلك استديو الالعاب الالكترونيه
من يونتي
وكذلك مركز الطيور الالعاب الالكترونيه
لكن وبنتقل لك وليد كذلك اعلان باستوديو
بناء الشركات او استديو الشركات رياضيه
بيعيام او منجم الاعمال
صندوق 100 مليون دولار
فعدنا مره ثانيه للي كنت تقوله من كم شهر
او تناقشنا فيه من كم شهر وش بيصير دور
استديوهات بناء الشركات
فنشوف تركيز كمان على جانب بناء القدرات
وكذلك بناء الشركات
اقول جيده لان في غيرها جيده لكن تحسين
فرص
نجاحها او تحسين حتى جوده المنتجات نفسها
الملفت خبر
انه كان بالشراكه مع مجموعه عقاريه
شفنا هذا الاتجاه في اكثر من استديو يعني
قبل المؤتمر فتره شفنا اكثر من استديو اخر
يوقعون مع لاعبين استراتيجيين فيبدا في
تركيز على نوع معين من الاستديوهات اللي
هو يكون شراكه استراتيجيه بين
الشركه الكبيره وبين الفريق اللي يدير
الاستديو ايضا شفناه
او لين فانتك نفس الفكره
فالسؤال طيب وين انواع الثانيه اللي مثلا
لا الفريق ينتج بنفسه المنتجات ويطلعها
الاسبوع السوكي سبينر شفنا مثلا في انهانس
لهم تواجد هنا في السعوديه مع محمد الحقير
هل في يعني توجه نشوف نوع اخر لانه هو طيف
واضحه بالنسبه لي الشيء اللي كان فعلا
بالنسبه لي خبر سعيد انبسطت عليه وكثير من
الشركات تتعلم بسببه اللي هي موضوع
الكلاود في
المحلية في خلال الاسبوع الماضي مع ليفعلن
خبرين لتوسع التواجد الكلاود واحد من
مايكروسوفت اجور بقيمه 2.1 مليار دولار
قبل كذا وقال بمليار ونص طبعا سياده
الدوله على بيانات وخصوصيتنا احنا
كمستعملين انا بيانات خارج البلد كانت مره
مهمه لكن ايضا كانت تسبب اشكاليه للمؤسسين
والشركات وصارت حتى التقييد لنموهم نوعا
ما بسبب عدم جاهزيه يعني او مستوى الاداء
اللي موجود في الكلاود المحلي فوجود
استثمار كبير ضخم من شركات زي هذه محليا
انا شوفوا خبر ممتاز
المؤسسين وراح يريحنا المفترض لو تحقق من
وحده من اكبر اشكاليات كنا اواجهها على
المستوى التقني في الشركات الرياضيه طبعا
تواجد الجوع راح بالتالي ينعكس يعني نتمنى
التطبيقات
تكون موجوده قريبا
يعني خلاص
هذه اضافه ترى الاستثمارات الكبيره اللي
قلتها وليد تقريبا شفت احد التقارير
تقريبا 800 مليون دولار مشاريع مراكز
بيانات في المملكه يمكن من اكبرها الصندوق
البنك السعودي الفرنسي او الفرنسي كابيتال
ب 213 مليون دولار
يعني المنفذ شركه المعمر لتقنيه المعلومات
فواضح واضح واضح يعني زخم مراكز البيانات
هذه موجوده تكلمنا قبل شوي عن المحفزات في
دول كثيره تحفز بناء على مراكز البيانات
هذه بت
تسعيره الطاقه او الكهرباء عليها او على
او تضمن لها نسبه معينه من الطلب فاعتقد
اللي يجي الان على اساس يبني هذه الفجوه
في
العرض يمكن يستفيد من بعضها اذا كانت
موجوده لكن بعد فتره اذا اكتفينا حتكون
اكثر منافسه
بين الشركات وبين المقدمين عاد صراحه
الحديث معكم لا يمل والاسبوع هذا بالتحديد
يعني كان اسبوع في زخم
وزحام من الاخبار الايجابيه المنظومه
ما ودي صراحه
ننتهي لكن
انا اتطلع ان شاء الله لحديثنا الاسبوع
القادم بمزيد من الاخبار الايجابيه باذن
الله شكرا لكم ويعطيكم الف عافيه شكرا لكم
وشكرا لفريق بودكاست السوق في اداره
الانتاج اصيل با فرط وفي التحرير
عيسى وفي الهندسه الصوتيه عبد العزيز
المزيد وساهم في التصوير كل من ياسر بن
غانم محمد الرفاعي احمد طالب وهاب موسى
وكمان ساعد في التصوير ياسر هذا السوق احد
منتجات شركه 8 للنشر والتوزيع
[موسيقى]